okay let's go over some Modern action
flick Essentials menacing bad guys check
Jason Statham kicking butt and spouting
clever onliners check a ton of bees
check wait what yep The Beekeeper is in
theaters on January 12th and it's full
of all you could want from an action
thriller plus you know all the bees this
movie is getting so much Buzz hey now
that I decided to take a look at some
behindth scenes action from it it
probably won't surprise you to learn
that Jason St gets sent a lot of scripts
after all when it comes to action Stars
he's as close to a lock As It Gets In
terms of box office success so it takes
a lot for a script to get to the top of
the giant piles in his office I'm
imagining his office also has a gym in
it but maybe that's just me but
apparently the choice to make The
Beekeeper was a pretty easy one in an
interview Jason talked about how he had
a longtime connection to writer Kurt
Wimmer but somehow they had never
managed to find a project to work on
together